Okay, Michael. You got the answer?
>> Yeah, I think, well I can work
through it, I don't actually have the number yet.
>> Okay, let's do that.
>> So, alright, so in a world where.
>> In a world where.
>> Where this is the hypothesis that actually matters. We're saying that X
comes in, the hypothesis spits that same X out. And then this noise process
causes it to become a multiple. And the probability of a multiple is this
one over two to the case. So, the probability that that would happen from
this hypothesis. for the very first data item. The one to five, would be
1 32nd. That's the probability that a one would produce a five by this process.
>> Okay. How do you, how'd you figure that out?
>> Cause the k that we would need
the multiplier would have to be five. And so
the probability for that multiplier is exactly one over
two to the five which is one 30 second.
>> Okay.
>> And so then I would use that same thought
process on the next one which says that it is doubled and the way that
this particular process would have produced a doubling
would be if with, with probability a quarter.
>> Uh-hm.
>> And, the next data element would have
been produced by this process with probability at
half, because it's k will be 1, and 1 over 2 to the k would be half,
>> Okay, I like this.
>> Right? The next one will be an 8th, because its
tripled,
>> Uh-hm.
>> And the last one is also a multiplier of 5, just
like the first one, so that will be one thirty second as well,
>> Mm-hm.
>> Alright but now we need to assign a probability
to the whole data set, and because you told me it
was okay to think about these things happening independently, the
probability that all these things would happen is exactly the product.
>> Right.
>> So I'll multiply a 32nd and a quarter and
1/2 and an 8th and a 32nd, so that's like a factor of 5 plus 2
is 7 plus 1 is 8. Plus another
3 is 11 plus another 5 is 16 and 2^16
is 65,536. So it should be 1 over, oh you already wrote it. 65,536. Yea that.
>> Yes that's absolutely correct Michael. Well done. Okay so,
that's right, but you did it with a bunch of specific numbers. Is
there a more generic Is there a general form that we could write down?
>> Yeah, I think so, we're doing something pretty regular
once I fell into a pattern. So, I took the D,
and divided by X, so D over X tells me
that the multiplier that was used, so that's like, the K.
>> So. D over x gave you the k.
>> And it was one
over 2 to the that.
>> Okay, so one over 2 to the that.
>> And it was then the product of, of that quantity for all of
the data elements, so all the i's. So product over all the i's of that.
>> Okay.
>> But we have to be careful because If it
was the case that for any of our xi's the
d wasn't a multiple of it, that can't happen under
this hypothesis and the whole probability needs to go to zero.
>> Right.
>> So they all have to
be divisible otherwise all bets are off.
>> Okay, so in other words if d of i mod x of
i is equal to zero and this formula holds and it's zero otherwise.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay. Sounds good. Okay, great Michael. So that's right and that
was exactly the right way of thinking about it. And now, what we're
going to do next, is we're going to take what we've just gone through.
This sort of process of thinking about, how to generate data labels. for,
you know, noisy cases and we're going to apply to it what I
think you will find will be a pretty cool derivation. Sound good?
>> Awesome!
>> Excellent.